let's get right into today's hatred mail
quick reminder about what hatred mail is
brace yourselves for the only
information that can successfully
penetrate a tin foil hats Patriot mail
written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom
all right this week's hatred drawing
some kind of an analogy of sorts between
me and Jon Stewart as you can imagine
it's not a particularly flattering
analogy and it's one that unsurprisingly
would be offensive to a lot of people
let's take a listen to it once again
David Pakman you literally show us all
what an absolute idiot you are David
Pakman looks like Jon Stewart with AIDS
Pakman you are fake news no difference
between yourself and CNN this guy David
is a leftist idiot go back to cuck
Minister I really like left tests if you
haven't if you weren't looking the
person spelt leftist as left test and it
reminds me of when people say that
something is not anti-semantic when they
mean anti-semitic or that sometimes they
just spell it somatic I don't know why
left test really struck a chord with me
well perhaps he's being clever here
because that kind of means that you are
the furthest left you have left
Lefter and then leftist oh that didn't
even cross my mind I think that's what
he was going for you know I think you're
giving this hate reott the benefit of
the doubt and I don't think that they've
earned it because they can't even spell
my own name right you write hatred mail
to someone and you don't even spelled
that person's last name correct no I
think they got it right three out of the
four times all right well listen Pat
apparently defending hatreds now which
hey you know what that's his prerogative
you can turn hatred mail into something
positive we have a coupon code hey tree
at 40 all lowercase
all one word hey tree at 40 big
tremendous discount Pat really really
liking that one hey tree at forty at
david pakman.com slash membership I
don't even know why that was so funny
Pat but sometimes something just tickles
you the right way
this happens a lot every both the time
we can kind of get through it yep